welcome back intermountain healthcare
and select health are working to keep
our community healthy and happy and
thank you to select health for
sponsoring today's segment as we talk
about high-value care that's accessible
and affordable joining us today from
select health is danielle jones hi
danielle hi how are you thank you for
having me of course a lot of important
things to talk about today and let's
just talk overall about how you guys are
helping keep nevada healthy yeah
absolutely select health is an
integrated health system with
intermountain healthcare and our goal is
really to afford accessible and
affordable healthcare to everyone in
nevada
our goal is to help people live the
healthiest lives possible and you know
healthcare is changing very quickly and
so now is the time to kind of look at
your options and see what can be done
yeah and speaking of the now there's a
lot of exciting things happening i think
2022 is going to be a great year for you
guys and our community let's talk about
what's going on yeah so we have some
great news we're really excited about
select health earned five stars from cms
it's amazing yeah so we're really
excited it's the highest score you can
get it's rated on one to five and that
really shows that a plan has good
quality care that they have good
customer service and there's over 40
measures that cms looks at across the
board to rate the health plan so getting
five stars is a huge deal we're really
the first ones to have that here in
nevada well congratulations thank you we
touched on that a little bit last time
you guys were here just how exciting and
important that is what should people be
looking out for when they are selecting
their plans and what should they keep in
mind yeah you know things are changing
quickly things change every year things
like doctors prescriptions um how much
you're paying so you want to look at
that all the time and the great thing
about this five-star opportunity is that
there's still an opportunity to enroll
for people maybe you're not happy in
your plan today or maybe you're just
curious what is a five-star plan
you can reach out to any of our medicare
experts and you can actually enroll in a
five-star plan that's allowed through
medicare um all the way through
november 30th 2022. okay so there's
still time and i think for everyone it's
always just a little overwhelming to
know where to start or where to begin
just real quick where can people go for
more information what's really the first
step yeah you can go to our website for
more information
there's our phone number you can call in
you can go to your local broker if you
don't have a broker we can help you with
that so there are a lot of resources
this is not a decision you want to make
on your own there's a lot of plans
there's a lot of information so reach
out and just get that little help and
we're happy to help well that's great
and just it's so important to make sure
you understand everything before making
your decision so thank you for breaking
it down for us thank you so much for
being here and congrats on the fox story
thank you so exciting all right more
information on your screen here thank
you to select health for sponsoring this
segment call
1-855-442-9940 or visit
selecthealth.org forward slash medicare
for more information